and 300 catholic bishops from across the
u.s. are gathering today for a week-long
retreat on the clergy sex abuse crisis
the meeting is taking place at a
seminary near Chicago organizers say the
retreat will focus on prayer and
spiritual reflection and not
policymaking Pope Francis convened the
retreat he's sending the priest she
serves as preacher to the papal
household the gathering comes as CBS
News has learned of several cases
involving nuns accused of sexual
misconduct Niki batiste has been talking
to women who say they were victimized
Niki good morning Nora good morning The
Survivors Network of those Abused by
priests or snap says it doesn't keep
count of sexual abuse allegations but
we've spoken with several people who
recently reported misconduct ranging
from forceful kissing to molestation all
carried out by nuns one woman who agreed
to speak on camera describes her
experience as unconscionable
this is sister Shaw yes this is sister
Eileen Shaw this is the nun Trish Cahill
says she can fight it in when she was 15
years old I would have done anything for
her I would have died for her at a
convent in New Jersey
she says she told Eileen SH all things
she'd never revealed to anyone about her
now deceased uncle a priest whom she
claims sexually abused her starting at
age five she gave me everything that was
lacking that I didn't even know I was
lacking I was so broken she filled in
all those pieces she now describes that
process as grooming saying Shaw applied
her with drugs and alcohol while
teaching her how to have sex with a
woman
I'm with my friends during the day and
I'm with this pedophile nun in the
evenings and on the weekends and in the
summer pedophile nun is a phrase I think
most of our viewers will have never
heard really wow that's really a shame
because there's a lot of them out there
it's the secret not yet told Mary
Dispenza is trying to change that the
demands of chastity and celibacy are
unrealistic demands for
any of us Dispenza a former nun from
another congregation remembers what
happened when a superior summoned her to
her room I knelt down right next to her
and she kissed me all over softly my
face and I want to say oh but it wasn't
bad but it was and I've carried it with
me till today through her work with snap
The Survivors Network of those Abused by
priests she says she would occasionally
hear about abuse or cover-ups by nuns
but since the publication of a grand
jury report identified hundreds of
pedophile priests in Pennsylvania
at least 18 people have contacted her to
share stories of abuse by religious
sisters we've heard so much about
alleged child sex abuse by priests why
haven't we heard about nuns a lot has to
do with with the culture of nuns which
are they are very very private by Nature
Trish Cahill reported her abuse to the
Sisters of Charity of st. Elizabeth in
1994 the Congregation paid her a $70,000
out-of-court settlement they had Canon
lawyers on retainer just for people like
me
shut her up pacifier telling your lover
and you'll pray for her and send her on
her way in a statement the congregation
tells CBS News the case was investigated
immediately when it was reported in 1994
and a settlement was reached that was
mutually agreed on by all parties we
believe that the sisters of charity
acted in a responsible manner
hi is this Eileen we've reached out to
sister Eileen Hall who Cahill says she
continued to see for years as an adult
you know we should discuss this at all
she just had up the Sisters of Charity
removed her from her role as a grade
school principal but reports she remains
a nun they're providing her with food
and housing while restricting her from
outside ministry I think it's really sad
in the meantime Cahill says the
settlement she signed wasn't enough to
help her deal with a lifetime of trauma
what is your hope
this is the beginning of many many times
more that I get to speak and I get to
educate and I get to possibly help
prevent this from happening to anyone
ever again
[Music]
Cahill says she believes other nuns had
to have known what was going on with her
she struggled with post-traumatic stress
disorder along with alcohol and drug
addiction that she says began with her
abuse the sisters of charity says
they're willing to meet with her to
address for continuing concerns
I tell you predators come in all genders
but you have to note that they seem to
know exactly go after and I think a lot
of people think nuns are maternal
they're safe and in this case according
to some of these victims wasn't well
what we have learned is that abuse
fosters and silence mmm
you have to talk about it so thank you
for your reporting Niki thank you